the girag an experience because he were
here at federal arms to in big titties I
mean he loves all of it and I'm so good
you could do it too yeah cuz I was told
I said look you've nineteen your own
insurance 226 they would give you weight
loss surgery and I don't want that I
said son go get the weight loss surgeon
I get your teeth is taking off and your
stomach - he's like mommy I don't sound
like no manly thing cuz I had it all
planned out I was gonna get his tummy
tuck and his titties cut off and I'm
gonna get him weight loss surgeon my fat
daughter she fat nice I'm gonna get your
tummy - my mama get your stomach cut any
number by you and ass cuz she have no
ass so and then I told my husband he
don't have no ass I was gonna buy him I
asked you know people getting cancer
from that asses yeah now when they take
the fat from you know not only take the
fat they get me a lot of fat they're
getting cancer from the implants what
titties ass implants Ohio do you know a
big a you do you there's no issue with
some people who get ass implants they're
starting to get cancer
all those ass implants are only a few
years old you know what I on this thing
I'm from the inner state of a little we
was coming up Joe if you wanted titties
and ass it had this thing going around
and I did a podcast on I said we didn't
people black people II know a plastic
surgeon world so the deal was you take
that government butter and you rub it on
your titties on your ass and they said
it'll make it grow yeah I'm not allowed
to you that's what we used to do back in
the day
watch up look at me yeah but look look
at me don't think it's from the butter
Oh everybody I know robot on there you
don't know that government butter that
[ __ ] was never my water job to get Oh to
kill everybody these doors on one side
moving a tub and with my name was like
just put the butter on your titty in
your ass we put the butter all on my mom
away cuz she said no you [ __ ] they
got my butt on y'all you know that [ __ ]
gotta last me 28 mo day she took that
stick card and she hit us and that
[ __ ] stuck in that bar
she gave us Windham wooden hoes I
scraped my [ __ ] off you [ __ ]
we're not scraping her butter all off
well she put that [ __ ] back in the
frigerator she beat this [ __ ] oh my god
she scraped the butter off your tits and
put it back in the fridge we can't waste
all that good bottle Joe oh my god that
is hilarious I was playing it on butter
magic butter really did that all you had
to do to get big tits in a big ass just
butter hey I'm happy this is the fourth
grade so that's what I did it like it
like you just have good genetics no job
I mama have no titties yeah but
sometimes it doesn't get your mom and it
goes to you Joe I'm trying to kill the
government but don't do that education
and [ __ ] Joe
don't break it all the way down for the
lady let him try to butter before they
try to pause it okay so go out and get
you some good old government butter that
won't melt and just sit on it
like a [ __ ] bird trying to hatch you
ain't just sit alright yeah your booty
and stuff just have a seat all right and
hopefully it'll make your booties and
titties girl it did work imagine that
works there's a lot of questions on
Yahoo people asking that does that make
your butt bigger and then I found the
product on Amazon called butter cream
for smoother fuller and firmer skin I
don't know that's what I hate natural
butt enhancement cream for women and men
plump booty enhancer lotion but firming
and tightening cream sexy but was it
once so a sexy butt lifter cream but
larger this is horseshit most likely
it's got four stars people that are
[ __ ] that work for the company
they're reviewing it 364 customer
reviews hold on click that the good ones
adding to my flat booty my family and a
in my family I inherited flat butt
syndrome it's embarrassing it's
embarrassing have your butt hurt because
you have no padding when you sit and
have no pants fall have your pants fall
because there's nothing in the back to
hold them up after week I def notice
something extra in the back I'll keep
using that's the people that you want to
buy your butt cream because they're
morons that's like people that give
money to preachers that fly on private
jets yeah I think that's crazy
that don't work but I'm telling you
government bought a work Joe I'm telling
you I flew this who would have known it
works faster on your breasted on your
butt but it's work more this is not real
[Applause]
God but listen the people that are
writing these reviews not only does it
works that's it
works not only does it works it
increased my breast size they probably
should change the name to breasts and
butt enhancement butter I know it for
the but I know it for the butt so I
figured let me see will it do anything
for my breasts since it's in quotes all
natural so I did so with within a week
my breast was fuller last time I seen
them this size was right before it was
time to breastfeed my baby is now nine
years old so imagine what we was doing
in the ghetto
I'm telling you that thick as mother I
mean it does work it watch how many
people who knows what I'm talking about
from the South stage oh we did that and
it worked I saw my Gucci tizen but we
should've done on one titty did it
what just to see no Joe I want to be I
know only one way to find out if it
actually works one cheek one tip you
bounce it out left cheek right to well
I'm gonna find that but but it rub it on
my crack baby one of her titties and see
if they grow on there just don't even
tell him what you
just put it on one today uh okay I'm not
to get her to do it I don't think I feel
appropriate how old is she now she's not
yes too late
no no she's uh therefore you can do it
you have a five you are contested on
what she already got a big-ass booty oh
yeah but I'm gonna get somebody to save
your work my husband will kill me I was
just I don't know if it's true but I
don't think it is it doesn't make sense
but then again I'm not a scientist I'm
telling you it's like that peanut butter
that they used to send to the ghetto to
choke Negroes out
[Applause]